hey you guys movie retrospective time
once again as you can see uh i'm on my
own for this one it turned out that the
the last day that we had to record this
before you know it so it could go up in
time uh tom remembered at the very last
minute that he actually had an eye
appointment uh at his thing like at the
va like an hour and a half away so he
wasn't gonna have time to record this
and may get it edited and stuff like
that to get up in time so i was just
kind of like you know what i'll just do
this one by myself because uh honestly
he was doing something and he missed the
first half an hour of it anyway and he
didn't really seem to be watching it so
you know so i just decided whatever i'll
just like do it by myself so so i can
get it up in time because this movie i
actually i kind of wanted to do this
when i was actually surprised that this
one got picked in the patreon poll i
just wanted to do this one because i saw
that it came up uh you know for free
like included with amazon prime and i
thought to myself gosh i remember seeing
that back in the theater when it came
out in 2006 and i couldn't remember all
that much about it pretty much the only
thing i remembered about it was that it
was okay
and that i remembered it sort of being
like
weirdly over the top in a way that i
wasn't entirely sure was intentional uh
so i was kind of like curious to see it
again interestingly i think this came
out i kind of i want to remember i mean
it was 2006 it was a long time ago but i
feel like this came out
really like in close proximity to
hollywoodland which was another
similar neo-noir type thing except that
was based around the death of george
reeves the original superman actor
whereas this one is
tangentially about the black dahlia
murder
now i will say if you haven't seen this
it was directed by brian de palma and uh
it kind of tanked his career in
hollywood i don't know if this movie was
the actual thing that did it um it
didn't make uh even its budget back i
believe it only made 49 million on a
budget of 50 million and he uh i believe
he went into your like into foreign uh
you know investors and stuff after this
so he didn't make any more movies in
hollywood after this i've heard and
again i don't know if this is the case
either that it also pretty much tanked
josh hartnett's career he was the lead
in this
because this movie was
not well received i don't want to say
all the reviews of it were negative at
the time i don't really remember reading
a lot of reviews of it and i remember
when i saw it in the theater
not thinking it was terrible but not
thinking it was all that great either
uh so this is actually based not so much
on the real murder
um it's actually based on james elroy's
1987 novel which is also called the
black dahlia now i haven't read it it
seems to be one of james elroy's more
beloved novels and i read a pretty
detailed plot synopsis of it and the
movie does seem to stick pretty close
to the novel as i said it doesn't have a
lot to do with the murder the murder is
kind of like i almost want to say it's
like a subplot or it's just kind of like
a you know it's mostly about other
things that are sort of surrounding the
murder
but the book is like that too so it is
actually
a fairly close adaptation to the book
but i think what ended up happening with
this
is that when the novel came out i kind
of feel like this was james elroy's
first novel
that he sort of got a lot of accolades
um of it being like an actual really
really good like literary novel from a
literary standpoint whereas prior to
that i feel like he had been more known
as you know like a pulp writer like a
crime writer so this was the one that
kind of cemented his place as like an
actual quote-unquote literary writer and
it was very well received so pretty much
as soon as it came out in 1987 uh the
rights were bought for movies but it
just kind of went back and forth and
nothing really happened with it
so then obviously uh in 1997 i think it
was uh there was an adaptation made of
another of james elroy's novels which
was la confidential which of course was
an amazing movie and was very very well
received so then a lot of other you know
production companies were looking into
adapting some of his other stuff uh and
that's where the black dahlia came in
now initially david fincher was attached
uh james elroy was very excited about
this because he had seen seven and he
really liked it uh david fincher
actually envisioned this
more as a miniseries and i kind of feel
like i probably agree with him on this
because
the movie
uh the original cut of it so i've heard
brian de palma's original cut of it was
over three hours long
and it had to be cut down by the
producers to
just about two hours
and
i kind of feel like that shows because
the movie although you can follow it
i feel like this is one of those ones
where
it's i mean because the story and even
the story in the book
is very very convoluted it's very
complicated there's a lot of side plots
going on uh that all sort of
interconnect with one another and i
don't know if just one two hour movie is
gonna cover all that so i do kind of
feel like if they
you know if they were gonna make this
into a single movie i think a lot of the
subplots could have been excised uh and
some stuff written around
because
this just comes across it's not a bad
movie it just comes across as
kind of muddled
and even when you get to the end and
there are these really long expository
scenes like you know saying where all
the links and everything get come
together
you know you're still kind of left going
like wait what you know what i mean so
it's one of those ones that
you know i figured it out like what was
going on but all the connections and
stuff aren't entirely clear because
there's so much stuff going on
that maybe didn't need to be in there
wasn't super relevant to the main plot
and i kept forgetting you know there'd
be like a scene with like one dude like
this you know minor criminal or
something and then later they bring his
name up again and i'm just like wait who
is that i can't remember like who that
is you have to like keep going back and
checking so it's that kind of thing so i
feel like david fincher's original idea
for this his original vision for this
making a mini series uh was probably the
way to go because this is a very
complex story now as i said this is not
really about the black dahlia murder
it's
it's a plot point in there um but
it's just more like it's almost kind of
like the launching pad for
this much bigger story
about uh you know the things that happen
like with the cops
that uh that are investigating it and
kind of like a a little bit looking into
sort of like the corruption that was
going on [ __ ] that was going on at the
time and
you know and there's another thing too
you have to think that even though some
of the stuff in the in the movie and in
the book
uh is true like the way they found her
body the you know some of her backstory
and things like that um in the book in
the movie the murder is actually solved
uh which obviously in real life it was
not so there's a lot of fictional stuff
that is
put in there
including the two cops who are the main
characters who are played by josh
hartnett and aaron eckhart
those two are completely fictional
characters and matter of fact uh i think
one of the original ideas is that they
were gonna have two characters from la
confidential like turn up in this one as
well like i don't think they were gonna
be like main characters but i think it
was gonna be like a cameo
but they ended up not doing that so uh
david fincher was attached at first but
he couldn't really get the actors he
wanted he didn't you know he couldn't
really get the mini series he wanted uh
he couldn't get the budget he wanted and
so finally he was just like okay i'm
[ __ ] off and he went off and made
zodiac which of course is a brilliant
film uh also not not really in the same
lines but you know still based on a
killer or like a real crime so he goes
off and then they get uh brian de palma
so the movie is obviously a neo-noir set
at the you know the same time period
that the murder took place which was
late 1946 early 1947.
uh it looks fantastic the cinematography
actually was nominated for an academy
award although i believe it lost to
pan's labyrinth uh but it looks
beautiful the costumes are beautiful uh
just the lighting is beautiful the shots
are beautiful it's a it's a gorgeous
looking film
uh pretty much it's funny how uh this
movie is just so based around los
angeles of the 40s uh not most of it was
not shot in los angeles most of it was
actually shot in bulgaria uh some of the
out exteriors like pantages theater and
stuff like that that was shot in la but
most of the stuff was not but you
wouldn't really know that watching it i
mean it looked v it looked very la-like
so they did like a good job with that
now what we have in the story um
some people i feel like some uh critics
thought that it was almost like
a parody
of a noir uh rather than a serious
attempt at a noir
and i will uh i'll back that up that
assertion but the weird thing about it
is that tonally it's very strange it
almost seemed to me and i know that some
of de palma's other movies were like
this too and he's no stranger to making
noir type movies and most of his movies
do have like a slight element of camp to
them and i do think that that's
intentional
but the weird thing about this one
is that it seems like it wants to be a
serious
noir film
but then it has some elements to it that
seem
intentionally like
parody you know what i'm saying and i'm
talking particularly of
uh you know just some of the dialogue
and some of the it seems like some of
the actors are taking it very seriously
and some of them are just like chewing
the scenery uh so it's just like it's a
very strange like
tonal uh whiplash type thing one of the
things i'm talking about and it's only a
couple of scenes i believe the actor's
name is fiona shaw she's great i've seen
her other stuff but
her character i love her character by
the way like i think her character even
though she's only in two scenes is my
favorite
part of this movie because she just goes
for it and makes just this ridiculous
like over the top i mean she is just
like it's just ham for days and i love
it so the first scene where she's
introduced she's actually the mother of
hilary swank's character
uh who you know i'll get into that in a
minute and when we first meet her she's
kind of like this rich uh socialite
married to like a really rich dude uh
who the family ends up having something
to do with the elizabeth short the black
dahlia murder and she just comes across
as this like foul-mouthed drunk and
she's just like she's super hammered at
the dinner table and she's saying all
kind of like catty horrible things like
to her husband and all this other [ __ ]
and then at the end like the one scene
where they're sort of like revealing uh
the very very convoluted um answer to
the mystery
she just goes for it man she is just
like screaming and flapping his like
mommy dearest on steroids and again i
kind of love it i kind of wish
that
the movie i kind of feel like the movie
tries to split the difference between
being a serious noir and just going over
the top with the parody of it i kind of
wish they had leaned in one direction or
another and honestly i love her so much
because she just like [ __ ] she
doesn't even give a single [ __ ] and just
like goes for it with the ham um i kind
of wish they had leaned more in that
direction because that would have been
really entertaining because i feel like
one of the things that maybe bogs it
down a little bit is that josh hartnett
who is you know a fine actor i've seen
him in other things he was you know good
in 30 days of night but he comes across
as very
stoic to a point where and i know that's
kind of what his character is supposed
to be like but he comes across as really
very
bland and very kind of overly serious
and it just contrasts very weirdly with
all of this kind of like crazy
over-the-top camp kind of stuff going on
so it's like a really weird
it's a really weird juxtaposition and
i'm not sure
how i feel about it it's a very strange
movie i had forgotten because like i
said i haven't seen this since 2006. i
actually saw this in the theater when it
came out because you know i was big
brian to palm fan and i was a big true
crime fan so i was like oh all right i'm
down uh and i remember i don't remember
hating it but i don't remember loving it
either i remember liking hollywoodland a
lot better which i think i saw around
the same time because they were out at
the same time um but i need to rewatch
that one too now think about it
but i didn't remember i remembered it
being over the top like i remembered
that last scene being like real mommy
like no wire hangers i remember it kind
of being like that kind of vibe um but
that was pretty much all i remembered
about it so i kind of feel like it might
have been better if they had just leaned
way into
the camp
uh and almost made it like a black
comedy
you know what i mean maybe that might
have like uh worked out a little bit
better so what we have as i said not so
much about the black dolly of murder so
what we're setting up
is there's two cops
uh lee blanchard and bucky biker biker
baker i'm not really sure how you
pronounce his last name i can't remember
like i just watched the movie last night
but i can't remember how they pronounced
it
so you have those two guys now both of
them were ex-boxers
uh and one of them i guess aaron
eckhart's character lee is known as mr
fire because he's real fiery and uh you
know josh hartnett's character bucky is
known as mr ice
so they're cops now and they're kind of
since they're sort of famous and
everything uh they kind of get used as
political tools because the lapd are
trying to get a pay raise uh this is not
based in reality or anything like i said
there is some stuff in here that's based
in reality like they talk about like the
zoot suit riots and stuff like that but
most of this stuff in here is fictional
these two characters are both fictional
characters um so don't get too bogged
down into
you know oh these are real people this
is real [ __ ] that's going on some of the
stuff that's going on in the background
is real but very very little of it uh so
yeah so these two boxers are coming
there and the cops trying to get a pay
raise so they stage this big
um like boxing match between the two of
them it's like big publicity stunt
they're trying to get this proposition
passed that will raise their salaries um
so they end up doing that so pretty much
the first
i had forgotten about this too like the
first 15 20 minutes of the movie maybe
longer
is just kind of setting up this whole
boxing thing and how
uh bucky is willing to
take a fall
uh because they're gonna give him like
eight thousand dollars or something like
that in 1946 money so he can put his dad
into a rest home because his dad has
dementia
uh so so that happens
now he starts hanging out like him and
lee become partners they're not homicide
investigators at first or homicide
detectives they actually work warrants
so it's more kind of like you know vice
kind of crime like you know looking
after people that you know skipped bond
or whatever the [ __ ] um so they're
working on that
so there's this whole convoluted thing
which sort of plays into it later on
that lee
he was after this dude i can't even
remember because it does not really like
relevant to the story but he was he is
worried about this one dude um
getting out of prison
because uh his name is billy dewitt uh
he's played by richard brake by the way
i forgot he was in this movie he's only
in like one scene i think so billy
dewitt was actually a dude that he used
to know who essentially was
the pimp
of hit of lee's now girlfriend k who's
played by scarlett johansson
uh he was a dick and he branded her and
all this other stuff and what lee did um
is he put ended up putting billy in
prison and then essentially started
shacking up with lee's girlfriend uh so
now him and kay are boyfriend and
girlfriend but
she says they don't have sex they live
together lee paid for her to go to
college uh you know he pays this
beautiful house for them because like i
said he was a well-known boxer so he has
some money and uh so so that's going on
but then this sort of like weird
three not three-way like in a sexual way
but like a threesome
sort of um develops between
lee and bucky and kaye whereas bucky who
is single um just hangs out at their
house all the time and all the three of
them go out together all the time and
they kind of set up like how nice a
relationship this is uh you know just
the three of them hanging out together
so there's this whole thing and then
there's like this other subplot which
sort of plays into [ __ ] later on
where
bucky and lee are staking out this one
guy who's supposed to go uh he's skipped
bond or something but they find out that
he's gonna go do a drug deal so they go
there and they end up like in a shootout
they end up shooting the guy and then
meanwhile while that's going on uh the
body of elizabeth short aka the black
dahlia is discovered like a couple
blocks away now because they're there on
the scene because they were involved in
this other unrelated shootout they you
know pop on over there even though
they're not in homicide
so what ends up happening is that
because they're sort of you know the
golden boys uh you know the police
department is grateful to them for
getting them a pay raise so they're kind
of like willing to let them do whatever
so they ask to be put temporarily um on
the homicide squad so they can
investigate uh help investigate the
black dahlia murder uh because for their
own reasons you find out later that lee
i guess uh i believe it was his sister
or something like that like she got
uh kidnapped or murdered disappeared or
something like that so he's kind of like
obsessed with protecting women it's
which is also kind of a thing uh with
what what what happened with kaye how he
rescued her from billy dewitt although
that was a lot more complicated uh you
know you find out later on that whole
story was a lot more complicated was
like bank robbery involved and [ __ ] like
that you know it bucky is interested in
solving the case but he is like a lot
more reluctant
so as the story goes on lee starts
getting obsessed with the case to a
point where he's uh you know on benny's
all the time uh and he's just because
he's not getting any sleep he's never
coming home he's becoming uh abusive
toward kay
and uh basically lee has to kind of uh
you know or rather bucky has to come in
and be like hey bro you know you got to
chill out now he ends up going
when uh billy dewitt gets out of prison
he ends up kind of going after him
and while that's going on bucky
starts to investigate like some of the
black dahlia case himself
and this ends up uh leading him to
hillary swank's character his name is
madeline who's this woman that he sees
in this lesbian bar who
it's funny because like everybody in the
movie keeps saying oh she looks just
like elizabeth short but the two
actresses hilary swank and uh mia
kirschner who plays elizabeth short you
know in
that you only she's dead like at the
beginning of the movie so you only see
her in you know screen tests like old
films and stuff like that
uh so the two of them don't look
anything alike uh they have they both
have dark hair their hair is sort of
styled similarly and they both have like
sort of glammy black clothes but that's
about as far as the that's about first
the resemblance goes so it's just very
weird that everybody just keeps saying
that madeline's like oh she looks just
like that dead girl i'm like well she
really doesn't but okay uh but yeah so
uh bucky ends up getting involved with
madeleine who seems to know something
about elizabeth short like i met her at
the lesbian club and
you know and she ends up saying later
that she slept with her and stuff like
that but she's like i don't really know
anything about the murder
but she doesn't want her name in the
papers associated with the murder
because her dad is some big [ __ ] big
wig who made like zillions of dollars in
uh real estate or not real estate but
construction and he built all this stuff
like under the hollywood land sign and
so there's all this other kind of [ __ ]
and they're just kind of like this
really really wealthy like
some somewhat degenerate insane family
as you find out
uh so bucky gets involved with her but
as it goes on she's kind of like your
femme fatale type of character uh it
ends up her like knowing a lot more than
she let on at first and that maybe she
has her own motives for getting all up
in bucky's britches so that whole thing
is going on too
and meanwhile um they're also
investigating some other leads having to
do with elizabeth short
um as i said they they find out they
find like all these stag films that she
was in
uh where she was doing like lesbian porn
and all this other kind of stuff so as
it goes on um i don't want to spoil too
much about it in case you want to watch
it like i said it's on amazon prime as i
said it doesn't really have that much to
do with the actual murder other than i
mean they got the the autopsy stuff
right like what was happened to her body
yes she was cut in half yes she had a
glasgow smile yes you know she had uh
you know head wounds that were
consistent with being beaten to death
yes her body was drained of blood yes
her body was uh washed before it was uh
left there and you know the so so the
crime scene stuff it's not a real
gruesome movie they do kind of show the
body
briefly a couple of times and it's
pretty accurate to what the actual body
looks like if you've seen the crime
scene photos which i have which are
horrifying um so they did get that part
right but other than that
uh this is
almost entirely a work of fiction um
most of the characters are fictional uh
the resolution of the mystery is
completely fictional although it's sort
of based on a couple of suspicions that
were going on at the time i believe
eliot ness um thought that maybe
uh the same guy that he suspected was
the cleveland torso murderer who i think
is like dr francis sweeney is i think
his name um he was convinced that that
guy might have also done uh done the
black dahlia murder i don't know if i
agree with that but that was what he
thought anyway so this kind of takes
that
but
puts it all you know what this kind of
reminded me of now that i'm thinking
about it it kind of reminded me of uh
from hell where they took an actual
series of murders um and had some
factual [ __ ] in there about it but then
it like weaves this big grand
conspiracy theory type of thing where
basically there were like lots of people
lots of really wealthy powerful people
involved in this murder for really
sordid reasons so i kind of feel like
this has the same vibe as that all the
people that are implicated in this like
in the murder uh you know the rich
family that's up there they are
completely fictional that's not a real
family so they're not like you know
impugning anyone's uh reputation or
anything like that most of these people
are not real uh so
i it's just that i'm not sure as a movie
this isn't it's an okay movie um but
i'm kind of interested one i'm kind of
interested to see what david fincher
would have done with it and if he had
been able to make it a mini-series like
he originally wanted
um i'd also be curious to see the
director's cut of it which was
apparently over three hours long because
i don't know i feel like there was like
i said the book is very very complicated
there's basically four or five different
subplots going on which they all kind of
intertwine
but you can get away with that in a book
in a movie you really have to kind of
you know distill stuff down to the
essence if you're just going to make you
know like a two-hour movie out of it and
i kind of feel like this could have been
more focused because there's a lot of
stuff going on
that
probably didn't need to be in here
because it was
even though it might be relevant in the
plot of the book
because there's a lot more you know
threads that tie together
in the movie i think they should have
focused more
on the murder investigation itself
instead of all this kind of other stuff
that was going on i know that they
wanted to do that he wanted to do
something more like oh i'm going to
focus on the two cops and how it affects
them but i kind of feel like if you were
going to do that they should have just
focused on that and i felt like that got
a little bit lost
honestly lee played by aaron eckhart he
was actually the cop that was supposedly
the more obsessed with it but he doesn't
get as much screen time uh basically he
he gets really interested in the case
uh he comes home and he's a raging jerk
wad and they're talking about how he's
on uh benzedrine and he's just like
flipping out and getting obsessed with
it and he gets kicked out the house and
then basically he disappears uh for a
large part of the rest of the movie
until like one big scene where you know
something bad happens but most of it is
focused on
josh hartnett's character bucky who
is not as interesting and is not as
obsessed with the case i mean he's
basically only
you know following it up because he's
worried about lee and he thinks that he
might know some stuff about that lee
didn't know or he might be involved in
something that lee wasn't involved in so
he's kind of just investigating it
almost because he feels like he should
or he has to because his friend was into
it i think it would have been more
interesting to focus on the character
that was actually obsessed with it and
how that
uh affected their relationships but it's
it's just kind of a strange choice to
focus on the guy that was just kind of
like reluctantly involved in the case
and not the dude that was like really
super into it so i kind of feel like
maybe i don't know maybe it could have
been like pared down i know it's based
on the book and i know the book has the
two things and it's kind of the same
but
for the movie i kind of feel like they
should have cut down on the characters
and they should have cut down on a lot
of the subplots and just focused on i
just i didn't they didn't need the
boxing stuff they didn't need because
that was
that was a chunk of the film i was like
i didn't even when i started watching
the movie and i was just kind of like
man how long is this boxing stuff going
to go on it's like you know when are
they going to find elizabeth short's
body so i just kind of feel like
all that could have been excised it
didn't really have anything to do with
or it could have just been
you know i know that it had something to
do with you know them being like kind of
the golden boys at the police station
and you know how they got to be partners
and stuff but that could have just been
a line or two of dialogue they didn't
really have to show it all of it and
like you know them doing the boxing
match and this big drama about it
because it didn't really have anything
to do with the larger plot so uh you
know i think that there's actually a
good movie in here like i said it's it's
beautiful looking it's very well
directed um but i just kind of feel like
it's too convoluted um you know it could
have been trimmed down it could have
been
focused more on one thing instead of
having all this other stuff going on
that because i kind of feel like all the
subplots get kind of short shrift
because you know you're it's not in in
service of the main
investigation so you know even though
some of those people did have ties to it
it didn't really matter all that much um
so i kind of feel like a lot of that
could have been cut out and honestly i
have to say and i'm not [ __ ] on any
of the actors but
i think some of the actors in this were
probably
not bad actors but just like miscast
maybe um and i would have
liked to have seen it with different
actors uh aaron eckhart is fine in it uh
scarlett johansson is fine in it um i
would have liked to see someone other
than josh hartnett oh he's fine but i
would have liked to see someone with a
little more charismatic
um and i didn't really buy hillary swank
in that role
so i kind of wish they would have got
somebody i think actually uh faruza bach
was uh up for that at some point uh
jennifer connolly i think was up for it
at some point or you know or that was
one of the ones that they wanted or they
approached um so i would have been
interested to see someone with with more
of a femme fatale kind of
vibe to her or somebody with like more
of a i don't know more of like a 1940s
glamour girl type thing like more you
know more like a
a starlet from back then actually maybe
scarlett johansson would have been
better in that role now that i'm
thinking about it maybe they should have
switched them no now that i'm thinking
that might have worked um you know what
i mean because k doesn't really k's
character is scarlett johansson's
character uh she's not really a femme
fatale she's just kind of like this
woman that's kind of caught in the
middle like in a bad situation uh even
though she ends up not being squeaky
clean later like i said it's noir uh
everybody has everybody has secrets
that's kind of the whole thing but uh
yeah i mean if you like brian de palma
it's not as bad as some critics uh would
contend
but it's not really all that great
either
and
it's kind of a shame because it seemed
like a missed opportunity because this
actually would have made a really good
maybe they should remake it somebody
should remake it because it seemed like
i mean from those plot synopsis the
philabel or the uh james elroy novel i
almost said philip marlowe i don't know
why but uh james elroy novel um it
sounds like it would be a good film i
don't know if i'd necessarily call it
the black dahlia because people i know
that's what the book is called but um
people might come into it with the
expectation as i did that this is
actually going to be about the murder
but it's
not really i mean it's in there but it's
kind of it's almost like a background so
there's i mean because there's so much
stuff going on in this so i really do
feel like this could have been really
distilled
down to the essence of that and then the
rest of the stuff just kind of like
minimized and i think this might have
worked out better with like a lot more
focus but you know yeah your mileage may
vary so
let's see what everyone has to say about
it in the comments have you seen it uh
if you haven't seen it go watch it on
amazon prime and tell me what you
thought about it especially if you're a
brian de palma fan uh tell me do you
think that this was worthy of his whole
career in hollywood being tagged i think
like i said everything everything he's
done since then has been uh you know
overseas or indie funded uh so yeah so
this kind of like um you know pretty
much his career bombed after this one uh
so do you think that that's justified or
not let me know in the comments and i
will see you guys on the next movie
retrospective
bye